[Applause]
[Music]
Cambodia is far from an ordinary country
it went through such a bad period that
this place became one of the poorest
countries with the bleakest prospects in
Southeast Asia
[Music]
you see sandwiched between two more
populous and emerging economic powers
Vietnam and Thailand this small country
a fewer than 16 million inhabitants has
one of the most horrendous cruel and
ruthless histories of the entire
continents and perhaps the entire planet
[Music]
in 1975 the Cambodian Communist Party
took control of the country for the next
four years until its downfall in 1979
the chimeras as the party members were
known perpetrated one of the worst
genocides humanity has ever known during
the existence of democratic Kampuchea
the name of the state ruled by the Khmer
Rouge between one-and-a-half million and
three million people lost their lives
due to their policies that's a quarter
of the population of the entire country
wiped out in just four years the
execution of political dissidents and
racial and religious minorities made up
most of this chilling figure because
nobody was safe that Muslims Christians
Buddhists people of one ethnic group or
another whomever the government
considered as an enemy of the revolution
was targeted by this purge
[Music]
yes the Khmer Rouge were crazy and of
course all of this crippled Cambodia's
development prospects for years to come
because how can you possibly recover
from something so horrendous as you can
imagine it was no easy task and yes
that's exactly what we're going to talk
about in this video today how cambodia
has changed since the fall of communism
both in the economic and political
fields we're also going to look at what
we can expect from this small Asian
country in the future because it's
located in one of the areas of the world
that has the most potential a 100%
dependent economy Cambodia has
experienced impressive exponential
economic growth in recent years between
1997 and 2017 its GDP has grown every
year at an average of seven point seven
percent its gdp per capita is multiplied
by more than three
[Music]
these are excellent numbers but what
exactly has such development translated
into well for example this huge economic
growth has meant that the population
living below the poverty line has
decreased from approximately 50 percent
to just over 13 percent and of course
with this date so you may think well Wow
things seem to be going really great in
Cambodia well yes and no the truth is
that right now the country is
experiencing what you could call a great
uncertainty it sits between China and
the Western actors that United States
and the European Union but let's look at
this step by step
we've already seen the Cambodian
economy's enormous growth in the last
two decades so that raises the question
what exactly does Cambodia offer what is
their economic model based on
while the answer here is simple the
textile industry and tourism the
powerful Cambodian textile industry
accounts for approximately 80% of the
country's exports and employs more than
700,000 people this industry is by far
the country's driving force in the main
source of income for many Cambodian
families by the way Cambodia has a
feature that is seriously harming its
developments and it could also be a huge
problem for its future Cambodia is still
a mostly rural country us than 25% of
the population lives in cities which
places it as one of the least urbanized
countries on the planet to give you an
idea of what this figure means its
neighbor Lao is nearing 40 percent under
these conditions access and provision of
educational services are very expensive
and difficult to manage most rural
schools don't have books or an internet
connection and people continue to look
to the countryside as a way of life this
explains why approximately 20% of the
adil population is illiterate well let's
not get off-topic the fact is that a
large part of Cambodia's economic
takeoff was due to another character a
protagonist who arrived with a huge wad
of bills and stacks of bricks under his
arm you want to know who's hiding behind
this sudden deluge of investments
well no surprises that would be China
China has spent hundreds of millions of
dollars in infrastructure and in
real-estate developments in Cambodia
it's very common to see a landscapes
full of cranes and imposing buildings
and skyscrapers under construction in
the last two years alone about 6,000
construction projects valued at more
than 11 billion dollars have been
approved and he has most of the buyers
in this promising new real-estate market
come from China typically between 50 and
80% of the properties of the most
luxurious real estate developments in
the capital pnom Penh are required by
Chinese but just a second because what
triggered such fervor are the Chinese
crazy about Cambodia well maybe but
there's another compelling reason the
poor supervision that Cambodia
implements on the source of money
invested as well as its lacks
regulations has led many Chinese
millionaires to use Cambodia as a refuge
for their money
you know in case things go a bit
pear-shaped in China but of course
there's two sides to every coin and in
this story it's certainly no different
so far we've seen the attractive face
but well what about the other side
[Music]
hunson China and the death of democracy
we've already told you what's happening
in the Cambodian economy but we can't
forget Hun Sen the country's Prime
Minister and a major player in Cambodian
news you see hunson was one of the main
opponents of the chimeras Maoist regime
and reached power in 1979 with the
Vietnamese invasion the Britain ends to
democratic Kampuchea and the horrors of
the Khmer Rouge led by Pol Pot since
then hunson has ruled the country
becoming seconds on the list of longest
ruling leaders second only to equatorial
Guinean leader Teodoro Obiang and so
what can I say at first glance the fact
that a ruler has been in power for so
long doesn't look good right
[Music]
the fact is that in 1993 Hong's an
approved a new constitution that at
least on paper would democratize the
country by turning it into a
constitutional monarchy with a
multi-party system that could allow for
a democratically elected prime minister
however 26 years have passed and well
there's still no trace of democracy the
Constitution exists but there's no
opposition because the regime itself
doesn't allow it and in recent years
things have actually got worse in the
local elections of June 2017 the
opposition party national rescue of
Cambodia achieved significant popular
support however their droid in last Lok
the Supreme Court controlled by the
Prime Minister ordered the dissolution
of the opposition party and the
imprisonment of its leader kam Sokka in
November the reason as is often the case
the opposition was accused of planning
an uprising after the illegal ization of
the opposition and the imprisonment of
soccer which led to other opposition
leaders going in to XR her Hansen regime
demonstrated that the political freedoms
promulgated by the 1993 Constitution
where I came down to it nearly cosmetic
but such a disregard for democracy and
political freedoms would have
consequences
US House passes bill to sanction
Cambodia's top officials you begins
process to hit Cambodia with trade
sanctions and it's precisely this that
can hurt Cambodia the most European
Union's trade sanctions although in
reality it's not about sanctions but
about Cambodia's withdrawal from the
European all but arms program a program
that benefits the poorest countries by
giving them access to the European
market through tariffs exemptions which
has greatly helps the Cambodian textile
industry to develop but of course in
order to profit from these commercial
advantages certain conditions have to be
met and one of them is securing human
rights and political and democratic
freedoms and it's precisely because of
Hansen's violation of these principles
that the EU is immersed in the process
of expelling Cambodia from this
initiative this expulsion may jeopardize
a good part of Cambodia's textile
production whose exports to the European
Union account for about 6 billion
dollars which in turn equates to 40% of
the country's total exports
and of course in the face of such a
threats the logical thing is for humson
to take a step back what do you think
well the thing is no nothing could be
further from the truth
hunson has not only reaffirmed his
position but he's blamed the European
Union for meddling in internal affairs
but hold on a second because if Hansen
doesn't really care about the sanctions
and this check on the Cambodian economy
is the Prime Minister condemning the
country to disaster
[Music]
well perhaps but the truth is just a bit
more complicated
what Hansen really has in mind is
decreasing their dependence on the west
by turning to China
moreover relations with Beijing is so
good that the support is mutual
see while China floods the Cambodian
regime with Aden investments Cambodia
supports China in the ASEAN resolutions
which condemn Beijing's military and
territorial expansion in the South China
Sea and just a second because that's not
all China reportedly signs secret deal
to stationed troops in Cambodia with all
this one thing is very clear Hun Sen has
become a Beijing man and is turning his
back on the West and he's just the
latest player to do so but now it's your
turn what do you think about China
wielding its power in Southeast Asia by
clashing its checkbook even at the cost
of humming political freedoms should Hun
Sen retract and remain more neutral
towards the West and China well leave
your answer in the comments below and I
really hope you did enjoy this video
please do hit that like button if you
didn't don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also please do check
out our friends of the reconsider media
podcast who provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine
also this Chao is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you in the next video